foreign
fighters let's dive in at media day for
UFC Fight Night Vera vs Cruz chido Vera
was asked to clear up accusations that
he likes to poke the proverbial bear his
opponent Dominic Cruz Vera explained
that those Antics come from the fact
that Cruz refused to fight him three
times before this fight was made video
courtesy of MMA junkie the UFC offered
me
not once but couple times like real
offers you wanna fight Cruz in this day
and I say yes
the same way suggested the last 20 guys
have fallen in the UFC
and he declined like three like three
times
the reason I don't know I don't care so
I just make that power like I was like
hey guys I got off for a fight he
declined
attack him or talk Shadow [ __ ] who knows
I'm I'm found in Twitter right and when
I see him face to face I was like
hey if you you wanna fight let's fight
like you know I just keep it real I'm
not gonna just walk and Sucker Punch you
I I'm not a [ __ ] but if you give me the
the wrong energy I'm sure we're fighting
at the pre-fight press conference former
Champion Dominic Cruz was asked about
his motivation going into the fight with
Vera and whether or not he still has
title aspirations why would I do this if
I wasn't gunning for the championship
it'd be pretty useless in my opinion I'm
sitting here still going even though
everybody didn't necessarily think I
could how grateful can I be sitting here
considering first of all I'm not
supposed to still be here according to
everybody else because of all the
injuries should have never won the
second title I won probably to everybody
else I'm the underdog in every fight
that comes up from here it's okay UFC
heavyweight champion Francis naganu
joined Welterweight Champion kamaro
Usman in Denver Colorado that trained
together ahead of usman's next title
defense Usman will defend his belt at
UFC 2 78 on August 20th in a rematch
with Leon Edwards nagan who posted the
video of the two training together to
his personal YouTube channel and spoke
about how Usman has transformed into a
complete fighter what a workout is
always
more challenging so thank you more
more resistant on everything on every
movement
well uh Usman is outstanding like people
don't realize they don't see that busy
Champion he's this but you have to
understand that he's a guy that was just
stepping in the spot as a Restless at
the at the beginning
he didn't even know how to throw a
proper one to man the man that now he's
going out there like strike people knock
them out being very confident and that's
why like they didn't know like later
than yesterday I was telling him like I
think when you stop fighting you're
gonna be fat you're gonna because it's
gonna be the first time ever in your
life that you you will afford your your
skin uh to experience something and then
when they experience that thing it's
gonna be like wow it's unbelievable how
it's discipline with all that resistance
training Usman surely must take his
recovery very seriously however
according to a recent tweet from the
champ there are others that don't
respect that aspect of the fight game
Thursday morning Usman tweeted that the
U.S anti-doping agency woke him up at
5am just nine days before his fight for
testing dear U.S anti-doping there's a
reason you make us fill out our
whereabouts so you know where we are at
all times disrupting our sleep at 5am is
just plain stupid next time I'll make
you guys follow me round all day in a
sit down with GQ Sports UFC president
Dana White answered questions from MMA
fans across the globe when asked by one
fan if Habib namerga medov is the
greatest of all time white was hesitant
to give him the highly contested title
what's up GQ I am UFC president Dana
White and I'm going undercover on the
internet and Habib namerga Madoff be
considered as the goat in the UFC
it's it's so hard obviously he's
talented enough I you know who knows
what he could accomplish but he retired
too early
I mean Jon Jones is probably going to
fight at heavyweight this year you know
whatever you think about John it's hard
not to call him the goat believe me when
I tell you I've tried to convince Habib
to come out of retirement we'll see what
happens over the next couple of years
but I feel like he left in his prime I
mean look at what he did to Justin
gaichi right before he retired
Liverpool Superstar meatball Molly
McCain has her next fight scheduled and
it will be on the world's largest stage
McCann will join the main card for UFC
281 in Madison Square Garden her
opponent Aaron blanchfield has won her
last six fights and is off to a 3-0
start in her UFC career UFC 281 will
feature the highly anticipated
middleweight title bout between Israel
arasania and Alex Pereira the UFC is
reportedly eyeing two other big names in
the middleweight division to headline
their Fight Night card on October 15th
first reported by Ariel helwani and
later confirmed by MMA junkie Sean
Strickland and Jared cannonir have
verbally agreed to a five-round
headliner at Las Vegas's Apex Arena the
pair both coming off losses at UFC 276
will be looking to bounce back and once
again get their names in a title
conversation at 185. two years ago today
UFC bantamweight and friend of thick boy
Studios Adrian Yanez earned his UFC
contract on Dana White's Contender
series Giannis posted to his Instagram
Reminiscing on the day that changed his
life two years ago today got a contract
that changed my life forever grateful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
fans of EA's UFC 4 video game were
treated to a surprise after the game's
most recent update featherweight
Champion Alexander volkanovsky is the
fifth player in the game to receive a
five-star fighter rating he joined
Daniel Cormier in a one-on-one interview
to talk about the five-star rating and
his fight plans moving forward check out
the full interview on Daniel cormier's
YouTube channel and Alexander the Great
I'm calling you for one reason and one
reason only my friend
to the club dog you are now a five-star
athlete it is for UFC 4. you joined a
very
select group of Fighters Alexander
volkanovski now joins at a Sonya Max
Holloway Valentina chefchenko and Amanda
Nunez looking for more original MMA
content check out the rest of thick boy
YouTube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shop show food truck Diaries and
Fight Night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action
thank you